been greatly weakened by the events of
Saturday morning and Saturday evening
are Moscow correspondents
Diana magnet is standing by for us in
Moscow and will be responding to the
events
and what is said by President Putin
let's go to that tape replay as
President Putin is expected to speak we
are expecting the taper play to begin
dear friends
today I address you once again all
citizens of Russia I'd like to thank you
for your support your patriotism and
your solidarity this table solidarity
shows that any kind of blackmail is
doomed to failure
there has been a tremendous coming
together of society a unification of
society
and there has been a Firm support of the
Constitutional order
and by all the leading parties
virtually the entirety of Russian
Society
all of them have been United in the face
of the responsibility to defend the
Homeland
all the necessary decisions were taken
as promptly as possible in the light of
this danger the defense of the
Constitutional order and the lives and
security of our citizens
the organizers of this Rebellion yes
cannot but understand that they will be
brought to Justice everybody understands
that this is criminal activity which is
aimed at weakening the country
and this was a colossal threat
from outside we are threatened
organizers of this Rebellion
betrayed those people
dragged into this organization
is precisely what the neo-nazis in Kiev
and the West wanted
they wanted Russian soldiers should kill
each other
the servicemen and civilians being
killed and in the final analysis that
Russia should fail but
and they wanted our society to be
fragmented to be splinted
and they tried to take revenge for their
failure at the front but they slipped up
they made a mistake
especially
with regard to the special services
which have
maintained their oath to the country
courage they self-sacrifice of these
organs these Studies have saved Russia
is the same time
also Patricks soon
yet
encouraged to fight against their
um
by turning back they avoided further
bloodshed
we have to think about the people who
actually
decided to do to make this step
which would have had tragic and
devastating consequences for the country
for Russia as a whole
I should like to thank
those commanders and soldiers of the
private company who took the right
decision to stop and go back and prevent
bloodshed
can Administration
and I urge everybody to make contact
with the ministry of uh defense or go
back to their homes
[Music]
This Promise will be fulfilled I repeat
it is the choice of each of you
a choice of the Warriors of Russia who
have acknowledged therefore
President
also for his uh role in office in order
to achieve a peaceful resolution
it is the Patriotic
duty of everyone the Patriotic
feeling of everyone which has saved us
and
has saved the country as a whole thank
you
well that was President Vladimir